il est millionnaire mais il se présente
en défenseur des simples travailleurs
iweb floppy pont il est direct mordant
et combatif il a promis d'annuler la
hausse du salaire minimum à 15 dollar de
l'heure et d'abolir la taxe ontarienne
sur le carbone the walls taxe il a rompu
avec une vieille tradition et il n'aura
pas d'autre car de campagne pour les
médias il n'y plus seulement que le
frère de web voici drogue vol celui qui
pourrait bien être le prochain premier
ministre de la province la plus
populeuse du pays
son avance dans les sondages et si clair
que les libéraux ont dépensé un million
de dollars pour une campagne
publicitaire pré électorales de cet os x
10 5 et 9 le vrai golf world le genre de
campagnes négatives qu'on associe
habituellement aux conservateurs ou à la
politique américaine
il faudra une grande avance et s'ils ne
remportent pas cette élection ce sera de
sa faute soutient cet électeur qui
conserve de bons souvenirs de son frère
rob à la mairie de toronto
c'était un politicien honnête et il a
fait ce qu'il avait promis de faire dit
il
il a réduit les dépenses de capitaux
mais la politique provinciale ce n'est
pas la politique municipale et le style
provocateur de ford en fait déjà une
cible des femmes en afrique asie est
haletante libéraux compare déjà dogues
font date dans le hall trump pour son
style et pour ses opinions
puis la course n'est pas encore
commencée que déjà deux fois doit faire
marche arrière sur une promesse qui
risquait de faire dérailler sa campagne
dans une vidéo diffusée sur youtube on
voyait des sommes folles promettent à
des promoteurs de sacrifier une partie
de la ceinture de verdure autour de
toronto au territoire pourtant protégé
24 heures plus tard ils reculaient
johnson habite dans cette zone de
protection il ne veut pas qu'on y touche
mais pour la première fois de sa vie ce
printemps il est devenu membre du parti
conservateur ontarien
notre île est désillusionné des libéraux
après quinze ans au pouvoir
ils sont usés par le pouvoir et les
scandales sur leur intégrité dit il ils
sont corrompus les déficits prévus par
kathleen wynne pour les six prochaines
années après 10 déficit en 11 ans leur
font perdre d'autres appuis
on nous a pas parlé de ses déficits là
en toute vérité c'est maintenant qu'on
découvrait sa cette femme ne suis pas la
politique ontarienne
mais la seule chose qu'il sait c'est que
beaucoup l'ontarien semble détester
kathleen wynne la campagne électorale
ontarienne sera officiellement lancée la
semaine prochaine comme en 2011 et 2014
les conservateurs jouissent d'une bonne
avance sur la ligne de départ mais une
déclaration incendiaire une promesse mal
avisée et tout pourrait changer
rapidement